we are on the path towards 400,000
YouTube subscribers I hope you will
subscribe on YouTube at youtube.com
slash the David Pakman show
let's talk about tax returns many
Democrats have been using different
methods to try to obtain Donald Trump's
tax returns that effort has not really
been supported by Republicans up until
now in fact last week I told you that
Republicans in the house actually voted
down party lines not to request Donald
Trump's tax returns from the Treasury
using an old rule which would have
allowed them to be provided to this
within a committee that has now changed
we now have two Republicans who have
endorsed the effort from Democrats for
two committees to request Donald Trump's
tax returns these are congressman mark
Sanford from North Carolina of course of
eloping to Argentina with his mistress
Fame and Republican Walter Jones of
North Carolina and as we know Donald
Trump is the only president or
presidential candidate in the last forty
years not to release his tax returns and
likely the candidate from the last 40
years whose tax returns would be most
relevant and interesting to see given
the growing situation with Russian
collusion possible conflicts of interest
etc at this point if there were nothing
to hide
wouldn't you just show the returns Pat
because not showing them is causing a
problem seventy-four percent of
Americans want to see the tax returns if
there was nothing concerning in the tax
returns you'd think by now Trump would
show them well he may not want to
release them because it would embarrass
him because people would realize that
he's not as rich as he claims to be sure
so maybe there's no actual conflicts of
interest there even though it's very
hard to believe but he could be hiding
them for other reasons as well yeah and
that we've given the list of six eight
and twelve different reasons why Donald
Trump might not want his tax returns to
be made public and to be super clear
here there's a method by which the tax
returns can be obtained period right the
House Ways and Means Committee and the
Senate Finance Committee along with the
Joint Committee on taxation they have
the power to request individual tax
returns from the Treasury Department if
they decide to do it they get the tax
returns that would not make them public
they would then be able
to decide whether or not to make them
available to the full house and that
would effectively make the tax returns
public and people have emailed me saying
hey David why isn't it against the law
for the president not to release their
tax returns 2016 and 2017 will be
remembered for many Americans being
shocked and surprised at how many things
aren't against the law that presumably
should be I think that is going to be a
theme of these years there's no doubt
about that and one of the funnier things
I saw was an explanation from
congressman Kevin Brady who's the
chairman of the House Ways and Means
Committee about why this is not a
mechanism that should be used to draw
out Trump's tax returns he said quote my
belief is that if Congress begins to use
its powers to rummage around and the tax
returns of a president what prevents
Congress from doing the same to average
Americans Congress does the same to
average Americans the government already
rummages around in people's taxes they
have an entire division that is called
the IRS which does this and not to
mention it's not just people's taxes
that the government is rummaging around
and it's also in people's phone calls
and people's emails people's
communications etc etc it seems like the
most bogus explanation for why this
shouldn't be done on the sort of basis
of privacy and it's great that these two
Republican Congressmen are doing this I
could see this trend continuing because
there may be a coalition there between
Democrats and then Republicans who are
from swing states or we're just never
with Trump to begin with yeah I mean so
we've got Democrats plus two Republicans
hopefully it'll grow the trend is going
in the direction as Pat is pointing out
of more elected officials wanting the
tax returns we have 74 percent of
Americans who want to see the tax
returns if we have the will of the
people represented by our elected
officials we should have more than
Democrats plus two Republicans who are
pushing for the tax returns today's
episode of the david pakman show is made
possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and
you can get the free five-day home Tryon
from Warby Parker check out their
glasses I use them when I'm not wearing
contact lenses I started with the free
at-home trial they send you five pairs
of glasses you see which ones you like
you send them back and whichever one you
pick they will put your prescription in
- I like this because I can actually
show the glasses to other people and not
have to just decide on the spot like in
an eyeglass store the eyeglass industry
is controlled by very few corporations
that keep the prices very very high even
over $300 for prescription glasses with
Warby Parker they start at just 95 bucks
mine costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS